hello my lord it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
thank you very much this morning tell us
about the inquiry well we receive a lot
of evidence and we can see it in the
news about the amount of stress and the
amount of problems that the current
ofsted inspection system creates it's
punitive when it should be supportive
and we want to see more consistency
around that inspection so that parents
and children themselves have a system
that really works for them what's State
of Affairs when a teacher is so
concerned about her ofsted report that
she takes her own life
we hear that sort of story all the time
you know I'm not going to comment on the
individual story apart from extend my
sympathies to her family but we hear
from schools up and down the country
from teachers up and down the country
who are leaving the profession in droves
because of the workload pressures and
the stresses that they're under that the
system is not one that they trust and if
we don't have an inspection system that
people trust then it's not leading to
the school Improvement that those of us
in the policy making as I'd want to see
of course you're going to look at all
options and possibilities hoping to
report in November of this year
what sort of things are you looking at
what how can the system be improved
well it's easy when you're wrapped up in
the system here in England to think that
it's the only way that you can inspect
schools and it's important that we do
have some external inspection I think
and it's important that schools are
accountable but we can look around the
world at other systems and what they do
you know we had a look at a whole bunch
of comparative comparative jurisdictions
around the world and already we can see
there is no other country for example
that has a single word judgment to sum
up the inspection
Wales have recently just abandoned that
so we think that there are some really
easy wins where we can just turn the
heat down turn the dial down while still
giving parents the information that they
need to judge their local schools but
what about those schools that are
outstanding and continue to be
outstanding every time they have a
survey by ofsted what are you going to
do about that
but those outstanding schools will
continue to be outstanding we like that
one word so they can put it on a banner
in front on the railings in front of the
school and I think there's a problem
with that I think it's problematic if we
start to have the whole system geared
around how are we going to do with our
ofsted you know it's skewing the system
as it stands we should be having
teachers focused on what's best for the
kids coming through the door for the
communities that they're in and when
they're doing that really well they
don't need a great big banner on the
school gate saying that they're
outstanding the parents in that
Community talk to each other they will
know that the school is doing well they
can then have an external view which
produces a report which shows them in
some detail what's the quality of
Education like how is the leadership is
it well governed is it safe most
importantly are the children developing
well and you need to see the range of
measures in order to be able to form a
really good independent judgment and my
Lord what do you say to those who say
you just
say
yeah that's just it's slightly
ridiculous frankly
um we all want a system that works well
for our children if we have a system
that's causing our teachers to leave the
profession in droves that's not serving
our children well and we need to fix it
you're reporting in November who are you
talking to in the meantime we have a
really good group of advisory uh
industry leaders members of the
educational Union we're surveying
teachers so we're talking to teachers
we're receiving evidence we want to hear
from people see what their experience is
see what they think could be done to
improve it and then we'll we'll produce
our recommendations and how do they do
that they can get in touch with us we've
got a website but if they go on to
National Education Union they'll be able
to find the website fantastic will you
come and talk to us once you've got the
report we'd love to look forward to
seeing you then